peyrens
je l'envoie point le procès verbal est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée remboursant les
outils de gestion de la crise sanitaire
et modifiant le code de la santé
publique sur la demande du gouvernement
j'informe le sénat
que des candidatures pour siéger au sein
de l'éventuelle commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion de ce texte ont été
publiés ces candidatures seront ratifiés
si la présidence n'a pas reçu
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
tel qu'il est prévu par notre règlement
chers collègues je vous rappelle que le
port du masque est obligatoire dans
l'hémicycle y compris pour les orateurs
qui s'exprime à la tribune
conformément à l'avis six ans la
conférence des présidents réunie le 1er
décembre dernier chacun des rares au
respect des gestes barrières
salon aborder maintenant notre
discussion générale
dans la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur olivier véran
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
avaient la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur président du sénat monsieur le
président de la commission des lois à
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur madame la rapporteure pour
avis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
lorsque je vous avais présenté en
octobre dernier seulement le projet de
loi qui est devenue la loi du 10
novembre 2021 le gouvernement avait
appelé à un effort collectif de
vigilance sanitaire malgré la situation
qui était alors beaucoup plus favorable
compte tenu des risques de reprise
épidémique liées à la période hivernale
je cite et à l'apparition probable de
nouveaux variants
un peu moins de trois mois se sont
écoulés et vous voici réunis aujourd'hui
afin d'examiner ce douzième projet de
loi consacré à la lutte contre la
pandémie de kobe de 19 ce texte le
gouvernement vous le présente dans une
période incontestablement difficile
marquée ces derniers jours par des
records de contamination ce sera encore
350 milles contamination qui seront
publiés ce soir voir un petit peu plus
et nous n'avions jamais observé des
chiffres pareils depuis début de la
crise sanitaire j'ai parlé de
raz-de-marée le terme me semble à la
hauteur du nombre de contaminations nous
avons connu plusieurs journées
consécutives au cid 200000 de 300 milles
et cette journée ne fera pas
défaut à ce comptage extrêmement
impressionnant le système hospitalier
est également mise à dure et dure rude
épreuve il y as 22 mille patients
hospitalisés pour qu'ovide
3900 en soins critiques et de
réanimation dans une période qui est
également marquée ne vous aura pas
échappé par la grippe mais en ayant su
par la suite de la bronchiolite qui
était particulièrement forte cette année
cette situation pour aussi vertigineuse
que c'est qu'elle puisse être demande du
sang froid et demande que nous prenions
nos responsabilités pour poursuivre la
gestion de cette épidémie sans précédent
depuis bientôt deux ans les français ont
été très courageux tout le monde
s'accorde à le dire ils ont fait face je
veux leur rendre hommage parce que les
sacrifices qui leur sont demandées sont
colossaux je comprends la fatigue la
lassitude j'ai toujours dit que cette
crise sanitaire serait une épreuve
d'endurance le texte que vous avez
examinait renforce plusieurs mesures
existantes des mesures qui nous ont
d'ores et déjà permis de contenir
l'épidémie et d'éviter des choix plus
radicaux je pense bien entendu à des
fermetures d'établissements recevant du
public au confinement al'inverse
d'ailleurs de ce qu'on constate dans
beaucoup de pays de l'union européenne
notamment certains proches de nous ce
texte de loi il s'appuie ainsi sur ce
que nous savons du virus est ce que nous
avons à disposition pour le combattre
efficacement
aujourd'hui malgré la présence d'un
variant extrêmement virulent si nous
pouvons envisager de vivre le plus
normalement possible sans empêcher ou
fermé massivement les activités du
quotidien c'est parce que nous avons
deux vaccins les français ne s'y sont
pas trompés 53 millions d'entre eux ont
reçu au moins une dose le rythme des
primo vaccination a augmenté récemment à
la faveur notamment du débat sur le
passé vaccinale comme nous l'avions déjà
connu lorsque le débat sur le pas de
sanitaires étaient arrivés dans l'agenda
public à l'agenda public qui avait
entraîné la vaccination de plus de 12
millions de français supplémentaires
il faut saluer parce que le choix de la
science et du savoir c'est toujours le
bon choix il faut appeler tous les
français éligibles à les faire également
le rappel puisque le rappelle la
troisième dose pour celles et ceux qui
le nécessitent confère une protection
bien plus forte encore contre les
risques de formes graves et
d'hospitalisations
oui je n'esquive pas nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts et nous devons
aller vers celles et ceux qui un peu
éloigné de l'information où notre
système de santé n'ont pas encore un
accès au vaccin nous devons aussi
inciter celles et ceux qui ne sont pas
hostiles au vaccin mais qui tantôt par
indifférence photos tantôt par
nonchalance ne franchissent pas le pas
et puis il ya également celles et ceux
que nous aurons du mal à convaincre par
des mesures pédagogiques par les
entretiens avec les médecins les
pharmaciens les infirmiers c'étaient
ceux qui pensent encore qu'on leur veut
du mal en leur proposant un vaccin qui
protège une partie d'entre eux se verra
peut-être convaincre par la mise en
place du pass vaccinale pour eux les
registres rationnelle ont été mobilisés
en vain mais nous ne devons pas relâcher
nos efforts toutefois à court terme de
nouvelles mesures de freinage ont été
décidés je pense notamment au nombre
minimal de trois jours de télétravail
par semaine pour les postes où cela est
possible au port du masque à l'intérieur
dès l'âge de 6 ans à la mise en place de
jauge pour les spectacles culturels et
sportifs nous avons
également décidé d'adapter les règles en
matière d'isolement et de quarantaine
afin de tenir compte de l'évolution
extrêmement rapide de la diffusion du
variant omicron des données virologiques
disponibles et du souci de maintenir la
vie socio économique du pays et la
pérennité des services publics sur la
base d'un avis rendu par le haut conseil
de santé publique le 31 décembre dernier
ces règles ont été harmonisés simplifiés
depuis lundi dernier enfin c'est
précisément l'objet du présent projet de
loi nous souhaitons renforcer plusieurs
outils de gestion de la crise sanitaire
déjà prévues par la loi en premier lieu
le projet propose ainsi un
approfondissement des mesures de
protection avec cette transformation du
pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale afin
de renforcer les incitations à la
vaccination mais aussi je le redis de
réduire les risques de contamination
une étude française d'ailleurs a été
publiée que j'ai pris connaissance ce
matin de qualité qui montre qu'à une
réduction de la charge virale expiré par
les personnes contaminées par le cos
vide lorsqu'elles sont totalement
vacciner
après la promulgation de la loi il sera
donc nécessaire de présenter un
justificatif vaccinale pour accéder aux
activités de loisirs au restaurant haut
débit de boissons aux foires séminaires
salons professionnels et transport
interrégionaux je le redis pour les
établissements de santé sociaux et
médico-sociaux et sauf en cas d'urgence
le texte maintient le dispositif actuel
du pass sanitaires en cas d'urgence rien
ne s'applique évidemment vous le savez
pour les patients accueillis pour les
soins programmés les accompagnateurs et
les visiteurs le projet doit provost
programme également jusqu'au 31 mars
2022 l'état d'urgence sanitaire à la
réunion et en martinique parce que la
situation sanitaire préoccupante
justifie de maintien de mesures de
freinage renforcé le texte adopté hier
en commission ont fait de même en
guadeloupe saint barthélemy saint martin
guyane et à mayotte par ailleurs le
projet de loi renforce encore les
mesures qui permettent de lutter contre
la fraude nous savons combien la
pratique de la fraude au pass sanitaire
peut être dangereuse pour les personnes
qui s'en rendre responsable toute
personne habilitée à demander la
présentation d'un pass pour ainsi exigé
la présentation d'un document afin de
vérifier la concordance d'identité nous
aurons sans doute le débat nous l'avons
eue à l'assemblée nationale la
concordance identité n'est pas un
contrôle d'identité les sanctions
encourues par un gestionnaire
d'établissements pour manquement à
l'obligation de contrôle du pass seront
également renforcés ainsi qu'en cas de
fraude nous proposons également un point
important que les services préfectoraux
puisse connaître des données strictement
nécessaire à leurs missions de contrôle
des mesures de quarantaine et
d'isolement afin de vérifier que chaque
personne concernée a bien réalisé le
test négatif qui conditionne
levée de la mesure dont il a fait
l'objet c'est en effet la condition
indispensable d'une maîtrise des chaînes
de transmission enfin je précise qu'il
s'agit là d'un sujet bien distincts de
ceux relatifs à la crise sanitaire nous
vous proposons d'entériner ce qu'avait
déjà été entérinés d'ailleurs dans le
plfss 2022 mais retoqué par le conseil
constitutionnel au titre de cavaliers
sociale le renforcement de
l'intervention du juge des libertés et
de la détention dans le cas de régime de
contention et d'isolement en psychiatrie
le texte a été modifié par l'assemblée
nationale sur plusieurs points relevant
de la police sanitaire pour s'assurer du
respect par les employeurs de leur
obligation de prévention notamment en
matière de télétravail mais aussi pour
adopter pour adapter l'application du
pass vaccinale aux mineurs ou encore
pour faciliter l'engagement dans un
parcours vaccinale des personnes ayant
commis une fraude au pass sanitaires il
a gagné également été complété par
plusieurs mesures visant à soutenir le
système de santé tels que la
prolongation de la garantie de
financement des établissements de santé
et du dispositif d'indemnisation de la
perte d'activité des médecins les
adaptations aux règles de cumul emploi
retraite pour les professionnels de
santé et la prolongation de la prise en
charge à 100% de la téléconsultation
en fin de texte qui vous a été soumis
réactive des mesures adoptées lors des
phases précédentes de la gestion de
crises sanitaires en matière de règles
de réunions des assemblées générales de
copropriétaires de constitution des
jurys d'assises ou encore d'organisation
des concours de la fonction publique
ce texte a été significativement modifié
à l'initiative de votre commission des
lois et de votre commission des affaires
sociales parmi les principales
modifications adoptées en commission je
relève en particulier que vous avez
souhaité définir des seuils de
déclenchement du pass vaccinale au
niveau national ou à défaut au niveau
local en fixant directement dans la loi
un nombre d'hospitalisations cible nous
aurons l'occasion d'en débattre vous
avez également proposé d'exclure
l'application du pass vaccinale pour les
mineurs là où l'assemblée nationale
avait maintenu à la différence en
sortant du pass vaccinale les seuls 12
15 ans pour toutes les activités extra
et périscolaire de nature culturelle
sportive par exemple vous avez souhaité
exclure la possibilité d'appliquer le
pass vaccinale ou le pass sanitaires aux
centres commerciaux et aux grands
magasins vous avez supprimé le
dispositif inséré à l'assemblée à
l'initiative du gouvernement pour
faciliter l'engagement dans un parcours
vaccinale des personnes ayant commis une
fraude aux passes on n'a plus le droit
au remords ou à la repentance peu
importe la terminologie vous avait
écarté le dispositif de sanctions adopté
par les députés pour assurer le respect
par les employeurs récalcitrants de leur
obligation de prévention en matière de
santé et vous avez restreint la prise en
charge à 100% de téléconsultation aux
actes s'inscrivant dans un parcours de
soins coordonnés nous aurons l'occasion
de revenir sur ces modifications lors de
la discussion des articles du projet de
loi les propositions d'amendements
présentés par le gouvernement ne puisse
pas l'ensemble des sujets de discussions
mais nous avons souhaité nous concentrer
sur les points les plus saillants à ce
stade mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous l'aurez compris le texte
qui vous est présenté ne bouleverse pas
à l'économie générale de la gestion
d'épidémie il vient renforcer et
enrichir les outils mobilisés pour
maîtriser au mieux l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire il demeure tout
entier guidé par la recherche de cet
équilibre difficile avec le souci
premier de protéger les français tout en
assurant la continuité de la vie de la
nation est en nous évitant
collectivement d'avoir à prendre des
mesures plus contraignantes ce gros
merci merci monsieur le ministre
je vais donner là la parole
rapporteur de la commission des lois
monsieur philippe bas
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame et monsieur les
présidents de commissions et mes chers
collègues
tout a été fait pour que ce débat soit
perturbé par des polémiques
vous me permettrez de ne pas y prendre
part
à ceux qui sont certains d'avoir
toujours raison
dans leurs raisons d'ailleurs
successives
je poserai
simplement mes propres doutes et les
quelques convictions qui ont pu s'en
détacher vous m'excuserez aussi de ne
pas recourir un vocabulaire
fracassant pour me faire entendre
j'ai toujours pensé que venant de leurs
représentants les français
ressentent la vulgarité
comme une humiliation et non comme une
marque de proximité
mais je ne prétends pas exercer la
police du langage
la vitesse de propagation du virus est
sans précédent
paradoxalement ce texte n'a pourtant pas
pour objet de répondre à l'urgence
sanitaire
pour la quasi totalité des français
le pass sanitaire est déjà un pass
vaccinale
nous disposons d'ailleurs d'un arsenal
législatif
considérable que le gouvernement ne
souhaite mobiliser qu'avec parcimonie
il s'est d'ailleurs raté avec lenteur
depuis l'annoncé faite par le premier
ministre le 17 décembre dernier quand il
avait quand il avait fallu mettre fin à
la crise des gilets jaunes ont décembre
2018 la fai avait été bouclé quand trois
jours et nous y avions coopérer à la
veille de noël
de même le parlement avait su adopter en
trois jours la loi du 23 mars 2020
créant le régime de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et nous y avions aussi coopéré
depuis lors le sénat a constamment
assumer ses responsabilités et s'étant
engagés dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
en conjuguant exigences sanitaires
respect des libertés et
contrôle parlementaire il a toujours
accordé aux autorités sanitaires les
pouvoirs nécessaires
en posant ses propres conditions
c'est dire combien serait inacceptable
toute mise en cause de notre esprit de
responsabilité
dans un contexte d'instrumentalisation
politique de la lutte contre le coc vide
par l'exécutif
quand on est confronté
à 100
200 ou 300 milles contamination par jour
sinon plus une réponse qui reposerait
essentiellement sur une forme
d'incitation vaccinal sous contrainte
entrant en vigueur à partir de la mi
janvier mais ne produisant ses premiers
effets qu'à partir de la fin du mois de
février il faudra du temps pour que les
nouveaux convertis à la vaccination
soient pleinement protégés n'est en
aucun cas à la mesure du problème
d'ici là au rythme actuel
c'est sans doute une dizaine de millions
de français très majoritairement
vaccinés qui auront été contaminées avec
des retombées et certaines sur le
système de soins qui sont aujourd'hui
très probable il est vrai que sans que
l'on puisse encore en déterminer la
mesure exacte le variant au micron qui
évince désormais le variant delta semble
beaucoup moins offensif et ouvre
l'espoir d'une sortie du tunnel
épidémique je veux y croire mais ici et
maintenant nous sommes confrontés à une
urgence sanitaire à laquelle le pass
vaccinale aussi utile qu'il puisse être
ne répond pas le désordre à l'école dans
le travail et surtout à l'hôpital auquel
le gouvernement n'a pas préparé le pays
ne sera pas réparé par des imprécations
contre les non vaccinés qu'il faut
convaincre au lieu de les montrer du
doigt au risque de les braquer
je suis
fermement partisans de la vaccination
depuis le début elle a déjà sauvé de
nombreuses vies humaines et alan sauve
encore tous les jours
ces effets indésirables doivent être
rapportées aux risques épidémiques
auxquels nous sommes confrontés que le
vaccin réduit sans pouvoir l'éliminer
il y à un large consensus médical en
faveur du sexe si des voix scientifiques
discordantes existent auquel il convient
bien sûr de prêter attention il n'y a
pas de choix plus raisonnable que de
s'appuyer avec humilité sur ce consensus
d'autant que les résultats positifs du
vaccin pour la santé publique sont
tangibles il atténue fortement le risque
d'être malade ou de déclarer une forme
grave de la maladie ce sont des fêtes
l'un des enjeux est donc essentiel est
donc bien aujourd'hui encore de
convaincre les hésitants de changer
d'idée sur la vaccination
d'abord pour eux mêmes et pour leurs
familles ensuite pour l'ensemble de la
collectivité nationale mais comment
faire pouvons nous imaginer réussir à
convaincre ceux de nos compatriotes qui
craignent le vaccin plus que le coc vide
en les outrages ans ou même simplement
en essayant de les circonvenir
vaccinez vous vous pourrez aller au
restaurant et au cinéma
pardonnez moi monsieur le ministre mais
cela révèle une piètre opinion des
français que de leur maître en main un
tel marché on ne peut à la fois faire
appel à la responsabilité de chacun de
nos concitoyens il est traité de manière
aussi infantilisante en situant l'ordre
de leurs priorités de manière aussi
dégradantes beaucoup de nos compatriotes
qui refusent le vaccin le font par
conviction
nous sommes en désaccord avec eux sans
doute car ils se mettent en danger leur
imprudence aggrave les tensions sur
notre système de soins fragilisée mais
comment faire évoluer leurs convictions
sans leur montrer d'abord un peu de
respect n'est pas juste de les accuser
d'être à l'origine de la flambée de
l'épidémie puisque les trois quarts des
personnes actuellement contaminées sont
vaccinés on ne peut davantage leur
reprocher de saturer l'hôpital car les
malades ducobu d'hospitaliser en soins
critiques sont pour près de la moitié
des personnes vaccinées si l'hôpital est
aujourd'hui sous tension c'est dû à la
fatigue collective d'une institution
éprouvé par le cos vide c mais aussi aux
contaminations au sein même des équipes
de soins mais ce n'est pas sans rapport
non plus avec une politique hospitalière
qui n'a commencé à s'intéresser à
l'usure de notre système de soins
qu'avec la crise sanitaire de ce point
de vue les non vaccinés ont bon dos en
l'absence d'obligation vaccinale les
personnes non vaccinées sont donc dans
leurs droits même si leur comportement
soulève un réel problème de santé
publique par conséquent le seul argument
médical possible en faveur du pass
vaccinale c'est l'argument de la
protection et non celui de la punition
nos compatriotes non vaccinés sont plus
exposées que les autres à une forme
grave de co vide surtout quand ils
appartiennent à des catégories
médicalement vulnérables ils ont donc un
intérêt majeur à se faire vacciner mais
s'il tarde à le faire ils doivent se
protéger plus encore que nos autres
compatriotes télétravail sites sont
actifs masque tels gestes barrières
tests réguliers et bien sûr éviter de
fréquenter les lieux qui les expose le
plus aux contaminations à commencer par
ceux où l'on mange et où l'on boit parce
qu'il n'est pas possible d'y porter un
masque comme à cette tribune nous sénat
avons déjà admis à trois reprises
l'utilité d'une contraintes sanitaires
pour l'accès à des lieux qui expose aux
contaminations et accepter de l'adapter
à l'évolution du contexte épidémique en
mai en juillet et en octobre à chaque
fois nous avons posé nos conditions et
fait en sorte que l'exigence de contrôle
de la représentation nationale soit
respectée et nous avons refusé les
chèques en blanc en imposant leur tour
devant le parlement si les paramètres du
pass sanitaire devait évoluer nous y
voilà de nouveau et ce débat législatif
que vous avez monsieur le ministre à
toute force voulu éviter en octobre
lorsque nous avions fixé l'échéance de
février vous avez décidé de l'ouvrir en
janvier sans enthousiasme je vais donc
proposé au sénat d'admettre ce
durcissement du pass pour des motifs de
protection sanitaire que j'ai énoncé
mais en assortissant notre accord de 4
conditions destinées à préserver les
libertés et la responsabilité de chacun
le maintien du pass ne sera pas laissée
à la discrétion du gouvernement actuel
est de ceux qui le suivront jusqu'au 31
juillet le pass s'éteindra de lui-même
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
les critères que nous aurons posé seront
réunis les entreprises accueillant du
public ne sont ne seront pas contraintes
d'opérer des vérifications d'identité
mais ce seront en revanche protégés par
la loi quand elles demanderont un
document avec photographie pour vérifier
qu'il correspond bien aux passes
l'inspecteur du travail ne pourra
substituer son appréciation à celle de
l'employeur sur la nature des postes
télétravail à bhl ni infligé à
l'entreprise de sanction pénale en
fonction de cette appréciation
les règles applicables aux mineurs de
plus de 12 ans pour leurs sorties
scolaires et extrascolaires seront
simplifiées et unifiée pas de passes
vaccinale en dessous de 18 ans si ces
conditions sont respectées je vous
demanderais mes chers collègues
d'approuver les propositions de vos
commissions nous adresserons aussi une
double mise en garde au gouvernement
face à la déferlante au micron il doit
sortir d'une posture attentiste
susceptible d'amplifier la crise est de
désorganiser la société l'école
l'hôpital et l'économie et face à
l'émotion causée par les propos
blessants tenus par le président de la
république la semaine dernière il doit
réparer au plus vite les torts faits à
la cause de la vaccination en renouer le
fil du dialogue avec nos concitoyens non
vaccinées dans ce domaine comme dans
d'autres il vaut mieux convaincre que
stigmatiser le président de la
république le sait d'ailleurs par
expérience qui déclarait il ya moins
d'un mois qu'il y a des mots qui peuvent
blesser sur le site que ce n'est jamais
bon et même inacceptable que je leur
site le respect fait partie de la vie
politique et qu'on ne fait rien bouger
si on n'est pas pétri d'un respect
infini pour chacun on ne saurait mieux
dire
merci sur le rebond peur
[Applaudissements]
je venais à paroles au rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des affaires
sociales madame chantal de seine
parole match et recollait
merci monsieur le président c'est le
président monsieur ministre madame
monsieur les présidents des commissions
mes chers collègues les effets des
variants delta est depuis décembre de la
rapide propagation du variant micron
conduisent notre pays affronte et une
double vague d'épidémie qu face à celle
ci est alors que la vaccination est
aujourd'hui notre principal est plus
efficace outil de lutte contre le virus
le gouvernement nous invite à
transformer le pass sanitaire en passe
vaccinale
l'objectif affiché est double
restreindre l'accès des nous vacciner au
lieu identifié comme propice à une
contamination et les inciter par là même
fortement à se faire vacciner il s'agit
donc d'abord de protéger les non
vaccinés eux-mêmes mais aussi de
répondre à l'impératif fondamental
qu'est la préservation de la santé des
français dans leur ensemble
or alors que notre système de soins est
sous tension et nos soignants épuisé
garantir la santé de nos concitoyens
c'est bien aussi prévenir des
hospitalisations évitables grâce à la
vaccination et donc réduire les
déprogrammations et la saturation de nos
hôpitaux et partant limiter les pertes
de chance si nous regrettons que le
gouvernement n'assume pas clairement une
obligation vaccinale de fait notre
commission a choisi de soutenir
l'adoption de ce nouvel outil concernant
les articles dont la commission des
affaires sociales s'est vu déléguer au
fond l'examen 4 prolonge des dispositifs
dans le champ de la santé
l'article 1er bis vise à prolonger la
prise en charge intégrale par
l'assurance maladie des
téléconsultations
l'article 1er quater prolonge le
dispositif des deux médecins libéraux
des établissements de santé
l'actrice le premier sexy elle ouvre la
possibilité d'une nouvelle garantie de
financement des établissements de santé
pour le premier semestre de 22 l'article
le premier cas caisse à étant une
nouvelle fois la dérogation aux règles
de cumul emploi retraite pour les
soignants notre commission des affaires
sociales n'a pas été sans réserve à
l'égard des nouvelles dérogations
proposé à la hâte dix jours après la
promulgation de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale qui aurait
légitimement pu les porter aussi même si
elle a validé l'essentiel de ces
dispositions elle a souhaité encadrer la
nouvelle exonération du ticket
modérateur
alors que le retour au droit commun doit
pouvoir se faire pour les
téléconsultations
deux autres articles issus d'un
amendement du gouvernement adopté en
séance concerne le droit du travail
l'article 1er bis a institué un régime
de sanctions administratives applicables
aux employeurs qui ne respecteraient pas
les principes de prévention des risques
d'exposition de leurs salariés à la
coved 19 le recours au télétravail est
en visée par le gouvernement les
employeurs qui sont déjà soumis à
l'obligation d'assurer la santé et la
sécurité de leurs salariés sous peine de
sanctions pénales se sont très largement
mobilisés depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire la commission a rejeté cette
nouvelle logique coercitives qui
n'apparaît ni utiles ni souhaitables et
qui donnerait une trop large marge de
manoeuvre à l'inspection du travail par
ailleurs l'article 1er octobre prévoit
un nouveau report des vies médical qui
doivent être assurées par les services
de santé au travail dans le cadre du
suivi de l'état de santé des
travailleurs
l'accumulation des reports pouvant être
préjudiciables
la commission on a limité la portée aux
visites et examens qui n'ont pas encore
été reporté en application de
précédentes mesures en outre afin de
prévenir le risque d'engorgement des
services de santé au travail à l'issue
de la crise nous avons à vous renvoyer à
2023 l'entrée en vigueur de la nouvelle
visite de mi-carrière prévu par la loi
santé au travail
janvier enfin l'article 3 relatif à l
isolement et à la contention dans le
cadre de soins psychiatriques sans
consentement qui vient complet combler
une triple censure titus ionel du fait
de la légèreté du gouvernement lors du
dernier plfss et malgré les
avertissements répétés de notre
commission des affaires sociales
l'abrogation 1er janvier laisse
aujourd'hui un vide juridique au
détriment de toute sécurité juridique
mais surtout de la sécurité des patients
et de la préservation de leurs droits
une saisine systématique du juge est
désormais prévue après un certain délai
qui peut ordonné la main levée de la
mesure où autorisé son maintien la
commission a adopté cet article mais a
souhaité notamment préserver la liste
actuelle des personnes informées en cas
de telles mesures au bénéfice de ses
observations la commission des affaires
sociales a donné un avis favorable à
l'adoption de ce projet de loi a ainsi
modifié je vous remercie merci madame le
rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues nous allons passer
la discussion de la motion qui tend à
opposer la question préalable
au collègue hervé a déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 35 tendant à
opposer la question préalable au texte
en discussion je vais lui donner la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le sénat
que j'aime c'est le sénat qui à la suite
du projet de loi safari a proposé la
création de la commission nationale
informatique et libertés le sénat que
j'aime c'est le sénat qui lie à 40 ans
le 30 septembre 1981 a aboli la peine de
mort
le sénat que j'aime c'est le sénat qui a
interrompu le funeste projet de
déchéance de nationalité
jalouse de son pouvoir législatif
la haute assemblée a dans son histoire
toujours été au rendez-vous la
préservation des libertés publiques y
compris quand elle a dû brider les îles
exécutif et ses excès nous en sommes au
12e textes législatifs en 22 mois la
caisse à outil n'est jamais assez
complète et à chaque fois le
gouvernement vient demander au parlement
de la compléter
ce faisant nous avons pris l'escalier
son retour de la limitation des libertés
publiques et nous devons nous poser
maintenant la question de la marche
arrière
je m'oppose à ce texte pour deux raisons
le pass vaccinale tout d'abord au micron
déferle sur la france et les personnes
testées positives se comptent par
centaines de milliers chaque jour y
compris et massivement parmi les
vaccinés je sais de quoi je parle on
devrait interroger légitimement sur
l'utilité des mesures privatives de
liberté actuellement africa dans notre
pays pour cela il nous faut des éléments
objectifs et chiffrés dont nous ne
disposons pas monsieur le ministre
ensuite il ya les contrôles d'identité
le texte propose de donner aux
responsables des établissements la
possibilité de vérifier massivement
l'identité de leurs clients mais quelle
mouche a piqué le gouvernement pour
avoir une idée pareille qu'elle
effondrement de la pensée et du débat
politique nous a conduits là quand les
résignés 10 on n'a pas le choix les
penseurs ne vois pas le problème quant
au visionnaire il affirme que ce n'est
la pas la loi qui limite les libertés
mais le virus je m'interroge où est la
gauche des droits de l'homme où elle a
droit des libertés où sont les
syndicalistes les universitaires les
intellectuels ils sont aussi rares ce
qui rappelle le prix de la liberté mes
chers collègues je vous propose de dire
un non ferme et définitif à cette très
mauvaise idée du pass vaccinale qui nous
conduit tout droit au contrôle social
généralisé alors je voudrais conclure
avec tocqueville monsieur le rapporteur
cet état se veut si bienveillants envers
ses citoyens qu'il entend se substituer
à eux dans l'organisation de leur propre
vie ira-t-il jusqu'à les empêcher de
vivre pour mieux les protéger de même le
plus grand soin d'un bon gouvernement
devait être d'habitués peu à peu les
peuples à se passer de lui
merci
y at il un orateur contre la motion
je suis au reporter
quel est l'avis de la commission ap
adorateurs contre la motion bien le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président c'est
presque un débat philosophique notre
très estimé collègue hervé viennent de
lancer est-ce que par principe il
devrait être interdit à la république
tellement attaché l'état de droit fondé
sur la déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen de restreindre ou de
limiter temporairement des libertés pour
faire face à une crise majeure cette
question a été posée à nombreuses
reprises dans notre histoire et pas
simplement du fait de la crise
épidémique elle a été posée lors de des
événements comme on disait à l'époque
d'algérie elle a été posée plus
récemment lors des émeutes des banlieues
en 2005
elle a été posée encore lors de la
récente vague terroriste et elle est
posée aussi dans le cadre de la lutte
contre l'épidémie
voyez vous dans notre pays patrie des
droits de l'homme les libertés sont
sacrés mais aucune liberté n'est pas un
absolu ayant le fondement de la liberté
c'est l'article 6 l'intégration des
droits de l'homme et des citoyens qui
dit que la liberté consiste à pouvoir
faire tout ce qui ne nuit pas à autrui
on n'est jamais allé plus loin dans la
définition de la liberté que dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui a
valeur constitutionnelle dans notre pays
et qui montre que la liberté se rapporte
toujours à des limites qu'il appartient
au législateur de poser ce que nous
faisons nous sénat depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire comme nous l'avons
fait dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
terrorisme ces dernières années c'est de
mesurer
avec la recherche du meilleur équilibre
possible les restrictions pour qu'elles
soient strictement nécessaires à la
poursuite d'une feinte supérieur en
l'occurrence
l'éradication de l'épidémie de covin 19
c'est pourquoi chers collègues tout en
vous ayant écouté comme toujours avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et d'attention je ne
peux pas partager votre point de vue
philosophique
dans la défense de cette motion et je
dois vous dire que je préfère de
beaucoup que notre sénat plutôt que de
refuser le débat
rentrer dans celui ci pour jouer son
rôle qui va consister précisément à
déplacer le point d'équilibré trouvé à
l'assemblée nationale pour faire en
sorte de limiter les restrictions à nos
libertés
pour qu' il n'y ait aucune restriction
qu'ils ne soient strictement nécessaire
à l'objectif de santé publique à juste
titre le président le gouvernement nous
demande de poursuivre avec lui dans la
discussion de ce texte c'est pourquoi
monsieur le président la commission est
défavorable à cette motion tout en re
mission tout en remerciant
l'auteur de la motion
de l'initiative qu'il a prise d'ouvrir
ce débat tout à fait captivant
merci monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis du gouvernement ministre
gouvernement défavorable il y at il des
explications de vote
oui je la roche
merci monsieur le président si je
comprends parfaitement l'exaspération de
notre collègue
devant ce énième texte dont on sait
qu'il n'apportera pas de solution réelle
à la situation aiguë de l'épidémie que
nous connaissons notre groupe ne peut
s'associer à cette motion oui le texte
présenté par le gouvernement n'est
qu'une obligation vaccinale déguisés et
ceux initialement pour tous les plus de
12 ans si nous combattons l'ensemble des
restrictions de liberté conclut dans ce
projet de loi notre assemblée s'honore à
s'emparer d'un sujet si grave alors que
le gouvernement a trop souvent considéré
notre ordre comme une étape dont il se
serait bien passé la conférence des
présidents a obtenu que ce débat se
déroule dans de bonnes conditions dans
une temporalité plus à même de faire
émerger des positions argumenté et des
contre propositions réalistes oui ce
texte est dangereux nous vous rejoignons
chers collègues sur beaucoup de points
et notre opposition nous engage à en
discuter il est essentiel que le
gouvernement souffre d' écouter nos
positions et nos propositions aussi si
nous comprenons les éléments qui
soutiennent cette motion nous pensons
que la tenue d'un débat est essentiel
nécessaire est plus que justifiée par
l'ampleur des conséquences de cet état
d'urgence sans fin sur notre pays
merci d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote
je n'en vois point
je vais consulter le
sénat sur la motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable je vous rappellerai
simplement mes chers collègues que si
elle est monsieur venait à être adoptée
ça entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
ceux qui sont favorables à fait
motion tordant reposer la question
préalable le manifeste en levant la main
avis contraire
attention
il n'est pas adapté
nous allons maintenant aborder la suite
de notre discussion générale et je vais
donner la parole à notre collègue alain
richard pour le groupe du rassemblement
des démocrates résistent mais
indépendant et pour six minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame et monsieur le président
mes chers collègues une nous faut donc
poursuivre l'adaptation de leurs règles
aux mouvements de la pandémie en gardant
comme point cardinal la sécurité des
français dont nous sommes coresponsables
avec l'exécutif et ce en laissant vivre
la société
la circulation du virus est beaucoup
plus intense
se maintiennent les formes graves
un haut niveau puisque si la proportion
de létalité du virus du variant omicron
est beaucoup plus faible la circulation
s'est multipliée par un facteur au moins
5 et donc nous sommes toujours exposé à
une surcharge du système de santé à un
nombre excessif de décès
notons l'impact déjà très favorable de
la vaccination qui réduit de plus de 90
% le risque de formes graves pour ceux
qui en ont bénéficié
nous recevons de nombreux messages
critique fréquemment impérieux pour nous
demander de refuser cette nouvelle étape
du pass vaccinale
il est légitime que les citoyens nos
mandants nous interpelle et nous devons
garder le respect pour leur sensibilité
pour leur argumentation
mais il ya une limite qui est celle des
injures et plus encore des menaces dont
les auteurs doivent être rappelés au
sens commun et si nécessaire à la loi
[Applaudissements]
et puis notre impératif centrale pour
nous législateurs c'est d'écouter la
science tous les cercles et institutions
légitimes offrant les garanties de
rigueur et de probité dans l'analyse de
cette maladie nous le disent à part des
cas de contre-indication rare et bien
des limites bien délimitées il est
confirmé que les vaccins approuvés évite
à 80 voire 90 % les formes graves sans
effets indésirables constatés après plus
d'un milliard de personnes vaccinées
depuis un an
nous devons donc
accepté la règle plus strictes qui nous
est proposé dans le projet du pass
vaccinale est donc refusé l'accès des
principaux lieux publics aux personnes
non vaccinées dans leur propre
protection comme ça bien été dit par le
rapporteur et pour freiner la
circulation
je serai observées aux collègues
qui ont réclamé avec de bons arguments
le passage à l'obligation vaccinale
que s'il voulait que cette mesure
s'applique il faudrait évidemment
qu'elle est aussi des conditions
d'application qui comme par hasard se
révèlerait être rigoureusement les mêmes
que celles qui sont réclamés pour le
pass vaccinale ce qui me laisse bien
augurer de leur vote sur ce texte
nous allons nous pencher sur quelques
cas de restriction et de dérogation
principalement celles concernant les
enfants et adolescents pour lesquels
nous préférerons pour notre part la
règle commune dès 16 ans plutôt qu'une
dispense trop générale allant jusqu'à 18
ans
le sujet de la fraude mérite notre
vigilance
si les enquêtes menées par la police
établissent d'ores et déjà
180 milles fausse vaccination faut pas
se vaccinant vaccinaux enfin sanitaires
pour l'instant les constatations de la
société française d'anesthésié et de
réanimation
font apparaître et c'est un tout autre
chiffre environ 5%
de personnes détenant un pour info passe
vaccinale dans celles qui sont
hospitalisés rendez vous compte mes
chers collègues que si ce sondage qui
est applications plus d'un tiers des
services de réanimation en france et par
les scientifiques
si ce pourcentage devait se vérifier
cela signifierait en réalité le nombre
de faux passe en circulation utilisés
par leurs détenteurs serait plutôt de
l'ordre de 2 millions donc le risque des
risques induits par la fraude doivent
être pris au sérieux et c'est pour cela
que la vérification de la conformité de
l'identité
du titulaire ou pas ce doit être fait
elle n'est pas plus intrusive que pour
encaisser un chèque ou pour acheter un
paquet de cigarettes
quand on a un abord un abord juvénile et
le risque d'être pris en faute réduira
significativement leur cour ouvre aux
faux parce qu'ils sont un vrai danger
donc il nous semble qu'il faut maintenir
cette disposition prévue dans le texte
nous préférons aussi
maintenir la faculté pour l'inspection
du travail de prononcer des mondes être
des amendes administratives
en cas de réelle prise de risque pour le
personnel soulignons que d'une part la
proposition qui a été faite par la
commission de retirer cette faculté ne
touche pas aux sanctions pénales qui
sont pourtant plutôt plus grave et plus
pénalisante l'entreprise que les
sanctions administratives
et rappelons-nous bien sûr que ces
sanctions administratives sont je dirais
parmi les facultés normal statutaire de
l'inspection du travail dans tous les
domaines qui touchent la sécurité au
travail
cette crise en caux encore en cours
d'accentuation pour j'espère une période
limitée mais une fois de plus en en
lumière le courage des soignants et des
autres professionnels des services au
public
enseignants personnels de sécurité
travailleurs de l'espace public et j'en
oublie ils sont un rappel vivant à notre
obligation d'être vigilants et efficace
dans notre mission de législateurs
merci
j'ai donné ma parole au président claude
malhuret pour le groupe les indépendants
[Applaudissements]
sur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
contrairement à ce que prétend depuis
des mois les trafiquants de fake news
les résistants des boulevards les a's
not been de la chanson française et les
sakharov de la dictature sanitaires nous
avons aujourd'hui trois certitudes
premièrement le vaccin empêche l'immense
majorité des formes graves
deuxièmement la probabilité d'un séjour
en réanimation est dix fois supérieur
chez les non vaccinés troisièmement les
services d'urgence sont remplies par la
petite minorité qui refusent la
vaccination
la conclusion est d'une simplicité
biblique il faut vacciner
faut vacciner le plus de monde possible
le plus vite possible
92% des français l'ont compris par les
anti vaccins depuis un an il nous tanne
avec leur convaincre plutôt que
contraindre nous disent de faire de la
pédagogie de ne pas stigmatiser ceux qui
stigmatisent tous les autres il faudra
bientôt vacciner en cachette et raser
les murs pour ne pas les déranger
eh bien nous ne l'ont pas raser les murs
nous allons répondre
et d'abord aux politiciens aux abois qui
essaient de se refaire la cerise on
philosophe de comptoir qui confondent
liberté et irresponsabilité aux agités
du télé bocal qui crient à la démocratie
bafouée l'est filippo asselineau le pen
dupont aignan ou melançon ce pacte
germano-soviétique de la désinformation
ont été
ont été successivement pour la
chloroquine contre le vaccin contrôle
pas sanitaires et maintenant contre le
pass vaccinale avec une infaillibilité
absolue dans l'ameublement ces amoureux
des dictatures il faut quand même qu'ils
soient gonflés pour accuser le
gouvernement et le parlement de prendre
des mesures liberticides
s'il avait été au pouvoir la vaccination
aurait perdu des mois et les morts
aurait été bien plus nombreux comme chez
leurs amis ball sauna roulante ivax ou
poutine aient sans vaccin est inopérant
réclamant agrandi réclamé à grands cris
par mélenchon et dont même les russes ne
veulent pas les français n'auraient eu
droit
les français n'auraient eu droit qu'aux
remède bidon d'un gourou rocambolesque
validé par la twitter school of man et
signer la facebook university ces
stakhanovistes de l'erreur et du cynisme
sont contre le pass vaccinale pas pour
préserver la santé de nos concitoyens
mais pour récupérer les voix des
extrémistes quoi que vous fassiez
monsieur le ministre pour eux vous ferez
mal je vous suggère une idée pour
vacciner les 5 millions qui manquent à
l'appel interdisez le vaccin ils
exigeront que tout le monde se le fasse
injecté
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ça suffit à 300 mille cas par
jour il est temps de répondre il aussi
plus que temps de faire front la
démocratie ce n'est pas s'agenouiller
devant une minorité inconsciente qui
peuplent aujourd'hui les services
d'urgence qui fait pleurer de rage et
l'épuisement les soignants voyant leur
lit rempli de patients qui n'aurait
jamais dû s'y trouver et qui en saas
tous les autres la démocratie ça ne
consiste pas à écouter des rebelles de
supermarchés sauter comme des cabris
avec leur pancarte en criant liberté
des quinze ans de ma vie comme médecin
dans les guerres ou les épidémies
j'ai tiré une leçon simple ce sont les
virus qui bafouent les libertés pas les
vaccins et si l'on ne prend pas les
mesures qui s'imposent c'est l'épidémie
seul qui en décident et toujours de la
façon la plus violente et la plus létale
il faut donc parce qu'il n'ya pas de
liberté absolue comme le disait philippe
bas tout à l'heure trouver l'équilibré
entre des libertés contradictoires et
prendre les bonnes décisions même si
elles ne plaisent pas à tous c'est ce
que vous nous proposez aujourd'hui
monsieur nice et c'est ce que nous
allons faire avec vous oui le pass
vaccinale est une façon de poursay la
vaccination et pour tout dire l'idéal
serait la vaccination obligatoire comme
il en existe onze autres sans que
personne ne lui hurle à la tyrannie
vous ne proposez pas
attendez la fin attendez la fin vous ne
proposez pas parce que vous craignez que
les boutefeux ne finisse par déchirer un
pays exténué et parce qu en démocratie
il n'y a pas de moyen infaillible de
l'imposer et vous avez sans doute raison
alors va pour le pass vaccinale les
offusqués professionnels diront que vous
créer deux catégories de français alors
que ce sont eux qui se place en marge et
nous met en danger ils diront que
voulait stigmatiser
alors que depuis un an il traite et
vacciné de moutons les soignants de
collabo qu'ils saccagent les permanences
des élus et les menaces de mort mais
nous allons poursuivre ensemble
calmement la lutte contre l'épidémie
malgré eux et avec l'immense majorité
des français
car en dépit des campagnes incessantes
sur les réseaux sociaux en ti sociaux
les français ont montré une remarquable
compréhension une remarquable patience
et une remarquable responsabilités
malgré les intox la france est dans le
peloton de tête des pays les plus
vacciner les réseaux ou même une vertu
après deux ans de bobards nos
concitoyens ont fini devant l'énormité
des fake news par se faire une solide
opinion sur ceux qui les diffusent et je
préfère ne pas répéter ici les épithètes
dont il les gratifie quant aux
discussions dans les repas de famille où
se trouvait un anti vagues pendant les
fêtes elles ont vacciné définitivement
des millions de français contre les
absurdités et se vexe aimable par sens
il est d'une grande efficacité
les faits
sa parole est maintenant madame la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président tout d'abord
je voudrais remercier les présidents de
beauf qui offre qui ont accepté que je
prenne la parole maintenant avant les
orateurs de la coupe monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2020
nous avions du mal à croire à une
seconde vague mais nous voilà début 2022
en pleine pandémie et d'autres peuples
fait face avec courage mais aussi
lassitude et résignation
oui il faut lutter frontalement contre
l'épidémie oui il faut vacciner et
protéger la population mais deux ans
après le début de l'épidémie bout ne
pouvait plus dissimuler la réalité c'est
l'insuffisance de moyens de la santé
publique qui pousse à la mise en oeuvre
de politiques autoritaires de
contraintes qui porte lourdement
atteinte aux libertés publiques
c'est l'hôpital public la médecine de
ville mais aussi l'assurance maladie qui
sont défaillants non pas du fait d'un
personnel qui est exemplaire de
dévouement et de courage mais du fait
des choix libéraux de ces dernières
années mathieu malgré la pro b ni par
emmanuel macron et votre gouvernement
alors nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
votre stratégie de rideau de fumée vous
masquez des mesures par des mesures
coercitives comme le pad sanitaire puis
le pass vaccinale pas des parm état
d'urgence permanent l'incurie d'un
système qui a ravalé la santé au rang de
marchandises je le souligne d'emblée si
le pasa mystère si le plan sanitaire a
boosté la vaccination force est de
constater qu'il n'a pas ralenti la
propagation du virus pour preuve trois
cent mille personnes sont testés
positifs par jour quelle est donc
l'utilité de ces sésames ce rideau de
fumée c'est aussi l'aggravation verbal
du président de la république autres des
millions de personnes non vaccinées dont
beaucoup ne le sont pas par choix mais
par éloignement faiblesse ou
incompréhension quelle est cette france
où l'on sont les gens pour savoir si les
soins doit toujours être accordée à ceux
qui refusent le vaccin oui vous
fabriquez des parias pour détourner le
débat et nous dénonçons ce jeu dangereux
nous proposerons par voie d'amendement
et cela en préalable à la discussion du
texte que l'entrée en vigueur du pince
vaccinale soit conditionnée à la remise
par le gouvernement au parlement d'un
rapport sur l'impact et sur le recul de
la propagation de l'épidémie de kobe de
19 car si comme je les dis se passe a pu
être utile faute de politique de santé
publique efficace pour inciter à la
vaccination l'on peut aujourd'hui se
demander ce qui légitime sa prolongation
et son durcissement
instrument auquel s'ajoute celui d'un
traçage numérique étatique banalisée
quittant lui-même à s'amplifier se
durcir comme le propose article 2 du
texte en étendant l'accent l'accès aux
données personnelles médicales aux
services préfectoraux il est temps de
mettre fin ce système de passes inutiles
sur le plan sanitaire et dangereuse sur
le plan des libertés publiques bien
d'autres solutions sont possibles des
solutions d'ordre véritablement
sanitaires et non sécuritaire comme
l'accentuation des gestes barrières et
des moyens de lutter contre la
prorogation le déploiement des tours et
détours hi-fi catr d'under la
distribution des masques ffp2
l'effectivité du recours au télétravail
lorsque cela est possible ou encore
l'organisation de roulement dans les
entreprises dans les établissements
scolaires par exemple plus globalement
il s'agirait comme nous avons eu nous
avons de celle de le soutenir d'investir
davantage dans la médecine de ville et
la médecine scolaire et de réarmer
l'hôpital public en bref des mesures
pratiques qui répondent à la crise
sanitaire en souhaitant protéger nos
concitoyens et non les punir enfin il ne
s'agit pas d'une épidémie mais bien
d'une pandémie la question est donc
mondiale est la seule réponse efficace
sera de cet ordre c'est pourquoi je le
redis encore il est plus urgent que
jamais de lever les brevets sur les
vaccins pour éviter l'émergence de
nouveaux variants seuls 50 % de la
population mondiale et vaccins idée un
plan de vaccination massive dans le
monde doit être déployée plutôt que de
taper sur le point du poing sur la table
en insultant toute une partie de nos
concitoyens
emmanuel macron aurait tout intérêt à
profiter de la présidence française de
l'union européenne pour convoquer un
sommet international et engagé un bras
de fer salutaire autour de la levée des
brevets sur les vaccins et d'un
gigantesque et ford aide au
développement en france nous avons
débloqué des centaines de milliards pour
l'économie combien pour la chanter
combien pour la solidarité
internationale
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
vous en conviendrez nous sommes prêts à
force de proposition et à débattre des
mesures propres à gérer la crise
sanitaire mais pour l'heure malgré les
tentatives du rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour atténuer
certaines mesures nous nous opposons à
cette énième projet de loi sécuritaire
et d'intimidation d'infantilisation de
nos concitoyens et de
déresponsabilisation
déresponsabilisation de nos dirigeants
emmanuel macron le 12 mars 2020 avait
annoncé extraire la santé de la loi du
marché or il est aujourd'hui payés à
notre pape dans son quotidien par des
décisions solitaire le refus de
s'attaquer aux dogmes libéraux qui
étouffe l'hôpital la santé et notre pays
nous refusons cette impasse sanitaires
mais aussi démocratique merci madame
président
[Applaudissements]
et donner la parole maintenant à notre
collègue guy benarroch pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoires
[Applaudissements]
la parole mon cher collègue
sur le président messieurs le rapporteur
cher collègue monsieur le ministre je
sers au parlement comme je me l'étais
pour tous les autres textes qui portent
sur l'urgence sanitaire on associe
énormément le parlement la démocratie
cote avez vous déclaré le 22 décembre
dans une célèbre matinale si je suis
désolé de n'avoir pas remarqué votre
présence toutes les fois précédentes
je suis ravi de vous voir ce jour ce
texte n'aura pas d'effets sur les vagues
en cours sur la désorganisation de la
société sur le drame de l'école m
l'ouvert coûte que coûte au lieu d'être
sécurisée coûte que coûte ce texte ne
répond pas à une nouvelle urgence
sanitaire ce texte n'est pas destiné à
freiner la propagation du virus ce n'est
pas son objet
les écoles sont en souffrance votre
doctrine de maintien des écoles ouvertes
se doit d'évoluer vers le maintien dans
de bonnes conditions
ffp2 pour les professeurs détecteur de
co2 quand même si vous affirmer qu'on
peut à errer sans les détecteurs c'est
plus simple de respecter les limitations
de vitesse quand on est un conteur
agir maintenant dans une phase explosive
de contamination est au mieux peu
efficace pourtant tous les signes
étaient là dès fin novembre
dès la montée du delta et avec les
premières informations sur au micro rien
n'a été fait à ce moment là malgré
l'avis du conseil scientifique
mais comme souvent depuis février
dernier le gouvernement cherche à
réfléchir seul jusqu'au dernier moment
les conseils de défense ou secret se
multiplient et les avis comme le dernier
du hcsp sur les ffp2 ne sont accessibles
que selon votre calendrier la droite
sénatoriale roumègue mais votent
toujours en essayant d'encadrer
périmètre est dur et nous sommes donc en
état d'urgence perpétuelle sécuritaires
sanitaires des quoi d'autre ensuite vous
focaliser sur des objectifs dérivés une
lutte contre leur confinement supérieur
à la lutte contre l'épidémie un désir de
sauver noël plus grand que celui de
sauver notre système hospitalier
derrière vos choix d' équilibre il y as
au mieux un attentisme optimiste au pire
incritiquable calculs politiciens
revenons au pass sanitaire puis
vaccinale à cette obligation vaccinale
déguisés et pourtant non obligatoire je
vous rappelle que d'autres groupes
écologistes a alerté dès le début est
régulièrement sur le risque d'une
généralisation trop importante de se
passe à la fois dans le temps mais aussi
dans son périmètre dans les activités où
les lieux qu'ils toucheraient ou même
les maladies ou cause qui entraînerait
sa mise en oeuvre le présent renforce
nos alertes et nous laisse augurer d'une
société de contrôle permanent camouflé
par des état d'urgence successifs et
récurrent doc nous voici devant un texte
qui prévoit trois types de passes
sanitaire vaccinale est un vaccinale
plus ça doit être ça le pragmatisme dont
vous vous réclamez sans cesse texte qui
prévoyait en plus l'obligation du pass
vaccinale des douze ans une obligation
vaccinale déguisée des douze ans
heureusement retiré par notre commission
sous l'égide de son rapporteur que je
salue cette vision séparatistes de la
société triés par les passes successifs
nous la rejetons
nous y sommes totalement opposés se
passe vaccinale ouvre en quelque sorte
l'accès à la possibilité de transmission
et de propagation sans autre moyen
compterait alternatifs comme les tests
pcr ou les masques ffp2 je rajoute que
cela laisse à penser que pour travailler
se déplacer sortir dans des lieux
publics vivre en quelque sorte nous
devons bientôt en permanence et
définitivement pour des années nous
faire vacciner plusieurs fois par an
mais se fasse se passe pourquoi insister
maintenant quelles nouvelles urgences
est connu en décembre il nous est apparu
que son efficacité était surtout liée à
l'incitation à la vaccination qu'il a
suscité et tant mieux mais comme j'avais
déjà eu l'occasion de le lire ici son
efficacité en tant que tel c'est à dire
les effets de sorts pouvoir de limiter
l'accès des personnes non vaccinées à
certains lieux de vie et peu étudié et
encore moins à quantifier sur le moyen
terme c'est pourtant ce pouvoir là qui
devrait juger aujourd'hui je le redis de
passe en tant que solution unique a un
effet pervers c'est une illusion de
croire une faute de laisser croire en sa
protection avec une circulation active
du virus et une immunité des clés entre
cette illusion s'accompagnant du
relâchement flagrant des gestes barrière
est un danger plus grand que vous ne
prenez pas suffisamment en considération
qui plus est une partie du public
prioritaire des tout premiers vaccinés
les plus fragiles les plus précaires les
plus pauvres les plus éloignés de
l'épisode de notre vie sociale ne le
sent pas suffisamment et ce ne sont pas
des anti vaccins le pass vaccinale
aura-t-il un effet protecteur sur cette
population où en sont les campagnes
d'aller vers votre but étant la
protection de la population
particulièrement la plus fragile c'est
là que doivent se concentrer vos efforts
à ce titre je vous demande aussi de nous
dire aujourd'hui la vérité de vos
attentions sur le besoin et les
modalités du quatrième dose et son
implication sur le pass vaccinale que
nous allons voter aujourd'hui peut-être
la vaccination est un outil majeur est
indispensable mais pas le seul pour
toutes ces raisons de vision et
d'installation d'une société de contrôle
et liberticide de mode de doom de
gouvernance de gestion devrais-je dire
verticale solidaire et fluctuant prenons
un peu chacun de nous à tour de rôle
comme irresponsable et utilisant des
outils de propagande critiquable de
succession de lois d'urgence sanitaire
de repos de plus dit un nouvel état
d'urgence ni un objectif de freiner la
comptabilisation notre groupe écologie
solidarité territoire votre encontre ce
texte qu'il tentera de rendre
acceptables par de nombreux amendements
merci de donner la parole à notre
collègue stéphane le rudulier pour le
groupe est républicain
[Applaudissements]
bon
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la même cieux les présidents de
la commission mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues notre
haute assemblée est une nouvelle fois
réunis afin d'examiner un texte traitant
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est le
douzième texte de cette nature depuis
près de deux ans alors l'idée même de ce
nouvel arsenal de mesures serait de
protéger davantage la population sans
devoir recourir à des mesures de
restriction généralisée dans un contexte
où la vaccination est le meilleur outil
pour permettre de lutter durablement
contre le virus
mais néanmoins et cela a été dit par le
rapporteur ce texte n'est pas une
réponse à l'urgence sanitaire ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas son objet il ne va pas
réduire le rythme de circulation de ce
variant au micron à court terme
par ailleurs sa mesure phare le pass
vaccinale qui se substituerait au pass
sanitaire n'est pas sans poser quelques
questions à nombre de nos concitoyens
il y a tout d'abord les anti pacs
arriverons-nous à
convaincre ces anti vax sans les
offenses et sans les injurier ceux qui
sont radicalement opposées au vaccin
seront ils plus convaincu par le pass
vaccinale qui ne l'ont été par le pass
sanitaire c'est toute la question de ces
prochaines semaines et puis il y un
certain nombre de forces de français
vaccinés eux qui sont totalement
désemparé perdu face à ce phénomène
d'accumulation de mesures prises par le
gouvernement et sur les contraintes qui
s'ajoutent les unes aux autres mesures
qui viennent parfois se contredire d'une
semaine sur l'autre je pense
tout particulièrement aux enseignants
aux parents d'élèves aux dirigeants
associatifs aux milieux culturels
comme je peux les comprendre car nos
féministes votre péché originel
c'est votre méthode de communication qui
peut paraître parfois totalement
incongrue par rapport à la nature des
annonces faites je vais prendre un seul
exemple quand une conférence de presse
du premier ministre et de vous-même le
27 décembre dernier
débouche sur l'interdiction de manger un
sandwich dans le train de consommer du
pop corn au cinéma de boire son café
debout ou encore l' annonce du retour
des fameuse jauge pour les événements
culturels ou sportifs qui ne sont pas
proportionnés à la taille des enceintes
j'ai envie de vous dire tout ça pour ça
cela pourrait sembler anecdotique si ça
n'entravait pas la bonne gestion de la
crise sanitaire en jetant notamment le
doute sur l'efficacité de l'action
publique et sur la nécessité de
poursuivre l'effort vaccinale alors il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire et à
redire sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement mais
faudrait-il pour autant transformer le
vote sur ce projet de loin en référendum
sur votre gestion de crise la réponse
est non je ne le pense pas ce serait
totalement irresponsable
au regard de la situation sanitaire le
sénat a d'ailleurs toujours fait preuve
de responsabilité a toujours été dans
une logique constructive et rationnelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
rapporteur a proposé de faire évoluer le
texte selon quatre grandes orientations
que je tiens rapidement rappelés en
premier lieu s'agissant du pass
vaccinale nous proposons mise en
extinction automatique sans pouvoir
discrétionnaire
donné au gouvernement
dès lors que la situation épidémique
s'améliore celle ci étant mesurée par
des critères cumulé qu'est le nouveau le
niveau d'hospitalisation sur le plan
national une circulation faible du virus
et un taux de vaccination très élevé sur
le plan local cette disposition permet
ainsi de garde lire de garantir une
proportionnalité entre les limitations
des libertés individuelles et la réponse
à l'urgence sanitaire j'en viens au
deuxième point la question épineuse de
l'expansion du pass d'accidents aux
mineurs le dispositif particulièrement
illisible conçu voté à l'assemblée
nationale doit être remplacée par une
règle claire qui nous semble préférable
seul le pass sanitaire sera exigé
jusqu'à 18 ans pour les sorties
scolaires ou encore les loisirs la
restauration ou les déplacements inter
régionaux s'agissant maintenant du
renforcement des dispositifs de contrôle
et de sanction nous avons une conviction
forte ce n'est pas la vocation des
restaurateurs des hôteliers des
quartiers en somme de toutes personnes
chargées des contrôles au sein des
établissements recevant du public de
jouer le rôle d'officier de police
judiciaire
en contrôlant les cartes d'identité ou
en identifiant des faux la commission a
donc strictement limitées
cette disposition mais c'est un point
qui sans nul doute fera débat au sein de
notre hémicycle dans quelques instants
enfin et pour conclure nous avons
supprimé l'institution d'un régime de
sanctions administratives pour les
entreprises ne respectant pas certaines
préconisations sanitaires tels que le
télétravail ce dispositif coercitif
kiehl sd pouvoir d'appréciation
tellement large sur l'organisation du
travail au sein d'entreprises par
l'inspection du travail risquer de
donner naissance à de nombreux
contentieux pour au final ne concernait
qu'un nombre très restreint
d'entreprises voilà mes chers collègues
le texte qui vient de la commission
propose au sénat de conserver la
position d'équilibré et de cohérence qui
a été la sienne durant la crise
de garantir la conciliation des
objectifs de lutte contre l'épidémie ni
de préservation des libertés publiques
et de garanties du contrôle
parlementaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle les sénateurs du groupe lr
voteront donc dans leur majorité le
texte des commissions espérons que la
majorité des députés entendre à la
sagesse du sénat dans le cadre de la
commission mixte paritaire et permettra
un projet de loi équilibré je vous
remercie mais furent domaine
la parole est à
notre collègue philippe bonnecarrère
elle veut que
de l'union centriste
mais ce président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
le parlement n'est pas le greffier de
l'exécutif
le sénat et le lieu du débat dans le
débat apaisé et nadir surprenante le
débat sur le post vaccinale a fait
l'objet d'une sorte de dramaturgie
dramaturgie à l'assemblée dramaturgie
peut-être aussi par les innombrables
mail que vous avez reçu les ans et les
autres je vous proposerai de la
relativiser le pass vaccinale et le pass
sanitaires - vous le savez tous la
possibilité d'accéder au restaurant ou
de prendre le train en se faisant tester
chaque fois que l'on voudrait y est
quel est le nombre de nos concitoyens
qui se faisait ou se font tester très
régulièrement à leurs frais depuis le 15
septembre pour se livrer à leurs loisirs
il est probablement très faible monsieur
le ministre vous avez été interrogée
lors de votre audition vous nous avez
pas donné d'indication mais nous pensons
effectivement très faible ce qui veut
dire que de quoi le pass vaccinale est
le nom de cette idée que chaque crise
doit avoir
une loi en réponse c'est ce qui explique
le fait que vous soyez saisi pour la
douzième fois monsieur ministre et
l'orateur précédent l'ont souligné c'est
finalement l'idée que le gouvernement
doit prouver qu'il agit et protège et
dans ce cas précis il propose le pass
vaccinale au lieu du pass sanitaire nous
sommes en réalité sur un changement
lexical si je devais résumer tout cela
pour cela pour le groupe centriste
la priorité va à la santé publique la
pression du quotidien assez considérable
et chacun peut la mesurer autour de soi
au-delà des statistiques qui nous ont
été rappelés autour de nous et au delà
des personnes atteintes vous avez pu
mesurer la réalité des copies de long où
la réalité des formes dur que telle ou
telle de vos amis aux relations a pu
subir sans être forcément hospitalisé le
virus est effectivement
très lourds très durs dans ses
conséquences et même avec un variant
moins virulent le risque pour nos
concitoyens et pour le système
hospitalier est majeur
la réponse est connue de tous la
vaccination
le pass sanitaires ou vaccinale est
certes une mauvaise solution pour les
libertés il n'y a pas de bonne solution
sur ces sujets mais force est de
constater que nous n'avons pas trouvé de
solution alternative meilleur pour
favoriser la couverture vaccinale dubé
c'est ce qu'explique que très
majoritairement avec la liberté de vote
qui lui est traditionnel notre groupe
approuvera le pass vaccinale avec des
conditions et des sérieux bémol ce qui
me donne l'occasion de remercier
philippe bas notre rapporteur pour la
qualité et la pertinence de son travail
la première condition est probablement
la principale est celle de
l'atterrissage de la sortie il est
facile vous le savez chers collègues de
déclarer un état d'urgence de se doter
d'un pass sanitaires ou vaccinale il est
beaucoup plus difficile de s'en extraire
de s'en sortir et sans comparer
totalement les situations vous avez vu
après 2015 la difficulté de sortir des
mesures antiterroristes dans la réalité
nous ne sommes pas sortis puisque nous
les avons les pérenniser c'est dire que
la clause de caducité est fondamentale
le passé ni terre doit être et rester
exceptionnelles il doit avoir une fin
notre à porter a fait une proposition
combinant nombre de patients
hospitalisés toute vaccination est au de
circulation se réserve d'ajustements sur
ses écrits terre ou sur la durée notre
groupe est très favorable à une clause
de caducité ou d'extinction automatique
du passé ni terre au delà des seuils de
référence à la date du 31 g pour nous
les deux choses sont liées si je devais
des résumés oui au pass vaccinale oui à
la clause de cas du sud deuxième
condition au deuxième bémol là situation
des jeunes permettant aux jeunes de 12 à
18 ans de vivre leur jeunesse notre
société a été dur avec la jeunesse de
france depuis deux ans nous partageons
l'objectif de la commission des lois de
donner plus de souplesse et de revenir
au système antérieur du pass vaccinale à
l'égard des jeunes c'est à dire les
permettre de poursuivre leurs activités
avec un test négatif
troisième bémol la vérification
d'identité il vient d'être évoquée par
l'orateur précédent nous sommes très
réservés
nous sommes ouverts à la discussion
le rapporteur a proposé qu'il n'y ait
pas des réplications de la carte
d'identité et la possibilité de
présenter d'autres documents portant une
photographie nous ne voyons pas très
bien à quoi correspondrait cette
situation une pensons plus généralement
qu'il y aura très peu de situations dans
lesquelles par exemple les restaurateurs
estimera qu'il ya une raison sérieuse
d'aller au delà de la production du pass
sanitaires nous sommes en résumé ouvert
les discussions mais objectivement très
réservé pas très loin de la position
de rejet proposé par le groupe
socialiste mais la discussion nous
permettra d'aller un peu plus loin
quatrième condition quatrième bémol la
sanction des entreprises en matière
télétravail les entreprises nous semble
et ils ont été impeccables dans cette
crise l ont bien compris qu'il était
essentiel de protéger leurs salariés nul
n'avait intérêt à ce qu'il y est un
cluster dans son entreprise au risque de
d'entraîner son arrêt d'activité nous ne
voyons pas de raison de renoncer à cette
situation de confiance et de rentrer
dans une logique de sanction reste pour
moi évoquer un autre sujet
c'est n'est pas ce qui est dans le texte
c'est ce qui n'est pas dans le texte
nous luttons contre les pandémies vire
au sens giral ni ajoutant pas la
pandémie démocratique ou présidentielle
vous le savez tous l'élection
présidentielle est la clef de la voûte
de nos institutions nous sortons de
dispositions légales ayant été adoptées
pour faciliter le vote aux municipales
pour faciliter le vote au départemental
et aux régionales comment pourrait-il
expliquer être expliquer qu'il n'y
aurait pas de facilité donnée pour le
vote à l'occasion des réductions
présidentielle et a fortiori pour les
conditions deux campagnes il ya même une
forme d'humour dans le texte puisque
vous avez un 1er septembre vous irez
vérifier qui donne au gouvernement les
moyens de faciliter la tenue des
assemblées générales de copropriétaires
vous motorisera penser que l'élection
présidentielle et a fortiori un sujet
ayant vocation à être traité en nous
savons que le sujet organique nous
autres groupes à propose à préparer une
ppl organique portant sur deux
procurations dédoubler les bureaux de
vote et élargir la campagne à la
télévision nous la proposerons à tous
les groupes de cette assemblée mais
avant nous souhaitons avoir la position
du gouvernement sur cette question et je
terminerai en évitant de rajouter ma
petite phrase à celles qui ont déjà pu
être prononcée à l'égard des
déclarations des plus hauts responsables
de l'état je ne crois pas qu'il faille
rabaisser les gens je ne crois pas que
quiconque ni à gagner à niveler par le
bas la société mais le vrai sujet c'est
que cette obsession cette idée qu'il
faut élever la voix pour être audible va
de pair avec l'accélération du rythme
électorale et avec le quinquennat et la
vraie cause de cette outrance que nous
constatons les uns et les autres autour
de nous c'est que l'outrance et
profondément la conséquence de la
malédiction du point qena
merci mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
me donner la parole à notre collègue
arize carrère pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
la parole ou chocolate
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues après les tumultes que
ce texte a pu connaître la semaine
dernière que les perturbations viennent
de l'exécutif ou de parlementaires le
sénat peut donc enfin se pencher sur la
question du pass vaccinale et je sais
que nous prendrons la mesure de
l'importance et de la solennité du sujet
de sorte que notre débat sera apaisée et
construit pour le dire sans détour le
groupe rdse dans sa grande majorité est
favorable à tout dispositif d'incitation
à la vaccination voire pour certains
d'entre nous à l'obligation vaccinale
nous voyons dans nos départements
combien les hôpitaux sont débordés et
épuisés et nous sommes également peiné
de voir les familles endeuillées alors
que certains patients s'ils avaient été
vaccinés oati guérir de cette maladie
car nous connaissons de mieux en mieux
le virus son mode de fonctionnement et
ses effets et plus les mois passent plus
nous avons de recul sur l'efficacité du
vaccin par exemple dans les
hautes-pyrénées sur huit patients en
réanimation
sept sont non vaccinés aujourd'hui il
faut donc trouver le moyen le plus
opérants pour achever cette campagne
vaccinale faudrait-il durcir
d'incitation comme le propose le
gouvernement à travers le nouveau pass
faudrait-il penser un nouveau mécanisme
d'obligation
comme peuvent le suggérer cette certaine
bien entendu le texte idéal n'existe pas
chacun trouvera toujours à redire du
dispositif choisi mais ce qu'il faut
éviter c'est l'immobilisme certains
membres du rdse ont pu très tôt se
prononcer en faveur de l'obligation
vaccinale au point qu'aujourd'hui avec
ce nouveau pass nous nous interrogeons
sur l'opportunité de maintenir un faux
semblant de liberté de choix c'est sans
doute trop tard mais un autre dispositif
aurait pu être imaginé en amont afin
d'épargner par exemple à nos
restaurateurs et nos cafetiers toutes
ces contraintes quotidiennes que nous
pourrions d'ailleurs encore alourdir en
leur ouvrant la possibilité de vérifier
l'identité des détenteurs de pass
il demeure que le chemin du passé ni
terre avait été choisi et que nous
poursuivons dans cette voie
reste à espérer que ce mécanisme
permettra de convaincre ceux qui pour
qui pour leurs propres raisons refuse
encore d'être vaccinés nous devons
néanmoins garder à l'esprit la
nécessaire mesure que ce type de
dispositif retière après quelques mois
d'utilisation du pass annie terre nous
sommes accoutumés cela suscite une
première inquiétude observer une
banalisation conduisant à un usage
excessif je ne vous apprendrai rien une
mesure administrative intervenants en
matière de police générale n'est légale
que si l'atteinte portée au libre
exercice des droits et libertés de
chacun est adapté nécessaire et
proportionné ce principe s'impose à
l'administration et donc au gouvernement
mais cela doit aussi guidé le
législateur lorsqu'il fixe le cadre de
l'exercice de cette police
administrative cela nous impose de
respecter une proportion équilibrée
entre la gravité de l'atteinte portée
aux droits et libertés et l'intensité du
risque encouru en l'espèce sanitaires
c'est une exigence de l'état de droit
aussi nous devons tenir compte des
situations spécifiques et ne pas céder à
la facilité d'imposer des obligations
trop général seulement au motif qu'elles
sont commandes à appliquer dans ces
circonstances le texte adopté par
l'assemblée nationale nous paraissait
encore perfectible par exemple la
question de proportionnalité des mesures
se pose encore une fois à l'heure où
jeanjean été rétablie dans de nombreux
lieux culturels
l'assemblée avait fait un pas vers plus
de flexibilité lors de l'examen du texte
en commission et nous regrettons qu'elle
soit revenue sur son intention en séance
publique pour y remédier un amendement
déposé au stade de la commission par
notre collègue nathalie delattre proposé
de réintégrer cette proportionnalité et
nous nous réjouissons que la commission
des lois est était du même avis en
adoptant un dispositif allant dans ce
sens dans l'ensemble les amendements
adoptés par la commission vente dans le
sens que nous attendions c'est à dire
d'assurer un meilleur encadrement
juridique du pass vaccinale de sorte
qu'il ne donne pas le sentiment d'être
un outil auquel tout gouvernement
pourrait recourir sans difficulté aussi
nous ne pouvons que nous réjouir de nos
premiers traits premiers travaux et
s'ils se poursuivre dans ce sens notre
groupe si montrera majoritairement
favorables à quelques exceptions près je
vous remercie
merci
de la parole à monsieur stéphane ravier
pour les sénateur n'appartenant à aucun
groupe
vous
2 je suis
non
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je ne m'adresserai pas
monsieur le ministre vu qu'il n'écoutait
aucun intervenant qui se succèdent à
cette tribune
est ce que le pasp rod est ce que le
pass protège réellement la réponse est
non cette phrase n'est pas de moi mais
de jean françois delfraissy le président
du conseil scientifique quel aveu
le ministre l'objectif du ministre n'est
pas de soigner ni même de protéger les
français son objectif n'est plus
sanitaires il est politique il veut tout
simplement donner l'illusion de faire
quelque chose en prenant la décision la
plus arbitraire et autoritaire que ce
pays et tu à subir depuis trois quarts
de siècle si son objectif était de
protéger nos compatriotes il rendrait
les tests gratuits pour tous il investir
et massivement et depuis deux ans dans
l'hôpital et la recherche mais rien rien
de tout cela n'a été ne serait-ce qu'à
mort c'est parce que tous vaccinés que
vous soyez mes chers collègues je suis
le seul le seul à m'être fait tester ce
matin et je suis négatif je suis en
mesure d'affirmer que je ne
contaminerait personne ici qui dans cet
hémicycle peut en dire autant la dérive
autoritaire et terrifiante et ce qui me
terrifie encore plus la docilité du
parlement de l'assemblée hier et du
sénat aujourd'hui qui va analyser vos
décisions sans que presque personne n'y
trouve rien à redire que les élus que
les députés de la république en marche
soit d'égoïste des godillots on le
savait mais que la majorité de droite du
sénat voté ce texte sans prendre en
compte les atteintes et irréparable
commises sur nos libertés
c'est plus qu'inquiétant c'est mortifère
oui vous êtes en train de martyriser la
démocratie aridi et la liberté vous
faites de 5 millions de français dont je
suis des sous citoyens des non citoyens
qu'avons nous fait pour mériter un
pareil châtiment nous refusons de
prendre la dose d'un prétendu vaccin qui
est tellement efficace il faut
l'administré tous les trois mois que le
masque est à nouveau obligatoire dans la
rue que des jauges sont instaurées dans
les théâtres et les stades que les
boîtes de nuit sont fermés bravo quelle
réussite nous n'en voulons pas
qu'importe le ministre nous l'imposent
de façon déguisée alors même que le
conseil d'état s'y est opposé en ces
termes
le pass sanitaire ne doit pas se
justifier par un objectif qui
consisterait à inciter les personnes
concernées à se faire vacciner c'est
pourtant clair et comme de l'état de
droit vous vous moquez vous devriez
aller encore plus loin il faudrait
écarter les non-vaccinés du reste de la
société les éloigner des vaccinés comme
gelée était sur le plateau de lci la
chaîne indigne pour masquer son
écrasante responsabilité dans le
développement de la pandémie en ayant
mis l'hôpital à loos la stratégie du
gouvernement repose sur la division en
désignant des boucs émissaires
conduisant à la mort telle division des
français sachons nous rappeler de la
citation de benjamin franklin qui
correspond parfaitement à ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre ce qui ce
qu'ils peuvent renoncer à la liberté
essentielle pour acheter un peu de
sécurité temporaire ne mérite ni la
liberté ni la sécurité alors mes chers
collègues en votant ce texte infâme vous
assassinez nos libertés sans assurer
notre sécurité ce texte est une honte
pour vous pour la république et surtout
surtout pour la france
la parole
l'ampli la parole
[Musique]
ah ah
la parole
un autre collègue jean-pierre sueur pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et un
geek
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers
collègues et cher rapporteur et rapporte
heureux et présidents et présidentes
notre position à nous a été clair
lorsque en novembre dernier à
l'instigation de notre collègue bernard
jomier que je tiens à saluer notre
groupe unanime a défendu ici
l'obligation vaccinale
pourquoi parce que nous croyons en la
science parce que nous sommes le pays de
pasteur parce que déjà dix vaccins sont
obligatoires dans ce pays nous avons
fait ce choix en toute responsabilité
nous le revendiquons et nous le
maintenons et nous étions seuls
le seul groupe à soutenir cela
et nous continuerons a présenté
l'amendement
qui conduira à l'obligation vaccinale
qui pour nous est la solution la plus
claire la planète la plus compréhensible
et mes chers collègues
j'ai pris connaissance monsieur le
ministre
de ce que dit la drees vous savez que
l'adresse est un service de votre
ministère vous le connaissez très bien
et justement elle a dit ceci je cite
si on avait opté pour la vaccination
obligatoire des plus de 50 ans au lieu
du pass sanitaire en septembre 2021 on
aurait évité 45 % des entrées en
réanimation entre octobre et décembre
fin de citation
alors mes chers collègues
c'est important
c'est d'important et après un long débat
très riche dans notre groupe socialiste
du sénat
nous avons considéré que dès lors que
nous étions pour l'obligation vaccinale
il était logique d'être pour le pass
vaccinale puisque cela se rapproche de
notre position mais nous persistons à
dire que vous devriez voter notre
mandement sur l'obligation vaccinale car
c'est parfaitement logique
toutefois nous serons extrêmement
vigilants mes chers collègues sur
plusieurs points qui justifie nos dix
neuf amendements et certains d'entre eux
particulièrement
premièrement pour ce qui est des
libertés publiques
et à cet égard je m'adresse à vous mes
collègues je m'adresse à notre
rapporteur philippe bas particulièrement
nous pensons qu'il doit être dit et
écrit clairement qu'il ne revient pas
aux responsables des établissements
recevant du public aux restaurateurs par
exemple de procéder à des contrôles
d'identité
il y a le pack sanitaires il y aura le
pass vaccinale une chose le contrôle
d'identité doit relever de la police de
la gendarmerie des personnes
assermentées mais il ne faut pas de
confusion et j'espère qu'au cours du
débat shdm adresse un autre rapporteur
philippe bas dont je salue le travail il
sera possible d'évoluer car je crois que
l'amendement que vous avez présenté
comprend un certain nombre de faiblesses
à cet égard
deuxièmement il nous paraît très
important nous allons le reprendre de
travailler aux dépistages dans les
écoles et collèges nous avions proposé
deux dépistages par semaine nous
maintenons cette position
et nous tenons à dire parce que nous
sommes au contact des populations dans
tous les départements de france que
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe dans
les écoles que c'est impossible d'avoir
un ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
chance l'opposition tous les deux jours
tous les trois jours quand c'est pas
chaque jour si bien que cela crée une
confusion une exaspération chez les
enseignants chez les parents d'élèves et
il faut vraiment eu en finir avec cela
ce n'est pas possible monsieur le
ministre de la santé de continuer comme
ça et je vous assure que quand je dis ça
nous sommes les représentants des
populations enfin je termine nous sommes
socialistes nous sommes très attachés à
la justice
et à la justice dans le monde entier en
effet et nous nous battrons toujours
nous déposerons un amendement sur la
question des brevets et sur la levée des
brevets parce que dans cette affaire il
ya quand même des questions d'argent et
des questions de profits qui sont
considérables et que alors que certains
ont droit à la vaccination
les peuples le grison de la pauvreté n'y
ont pas droit
c'est une injustice nous devons lutter
pour l'égalité
à cet égard je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
l'on donné la parole notre collègue
florence lassarade pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avec 90% de
france éligibles vacciner même
partiellement je voulais d'abord
souligner qu'il ya un an personne
n'aurait espéré ose espérer un tel
succès le choix de la science le choix
de la responsabilité est toujours le bon
choix et c'est celui qui a été fait par
la grande majorité des français certes
la vaccination n'empêche pas totalement
d'être contaminés ou de transmettre le
virus mais elle réduit considérablement
le risque d'être hospitalisé admis en
réanimation et même de mourir du coc
vide ce bilan est déjà très positif même
si la vaccination nous a pas encore
permis de reprendre une vie normale nous
considérons qu'elle constitue l'un des
meilleurs outils pour lutter contre les
dangers de l'épidémie actuellement le
problème majeur c'est le problème des
effectifs à l'hôpital et l'épuisement
des soignants la vague au micro onde
n'en finit pas de monter le taux de
positivité des tests a atteint des
niveaux jusqu'à présent inédit 20%
toutes les régions toutes les tranches
d'âge sont touchées par cette hausse la
pression sur l'hôpital s'accroît avec
une hausse régulière des
hospitalisations et l'incidence de l'aco
vide augmente chez les plus âgés ce qui
pourrait dans quelques semaines avoir un
impact important sur l'hôpital avec un
risque de saturation
comment allez-vous faire face au manque
de personnel au moment où le nombre
d'hospitalisations progresse les
conséquences sont déjà lourdes pour les
autres passions les déprogrammations
pourraient être évités si les lits de
réanimation n'étaient pas occupés par
des personnes non vaccinées cette
situation pose la question de la
responsabilité individuelle et de la
responsabilité collective par rapport à
la vaccination face à un virus qui
évolue constamment il est nécessaire
d'adapter des outils pour le combattre
mais il faut aussi anticiper
et là monsieur le ministre nous
regrettons le manque d'anticipation de
la part du gouvernement en effet les
personnes actuellement ranimation sont
majoritairement touchés par le ver lyon
delta qui n'est pas apparue ces jours-ci
seulement le texte aurait dû être
programmé à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée bien plus tôt et non pas au
moment où l'épidémie flambent le projet
de loi sur le pass vaccinale ne produira
en effet ses premiers effets qu'à partir
la boue de la fin du mois de février
nous sommes majoritairement favorable
vous l'avez compris à la vaccination aux
pattes vaccinale parce qu'il contribue à
augmenter la couverture vaccinale et que
la situation des hôpitaux nous le
commande
les services hospitaliers sont saturés
car cinq millions de français ont fait
le choix de ne pas se faire vacciner il
nous faut poursuivre nos efforts en
transformant le pass and i ter en passe
vaccinale et en renforçant les mesures
de lutte contre la fraude nous
proposerons aussi un certain nombre de
mesures pour améliorer la protection de
tous les français face à l'épidémie
j'ai proposé notamment des amendements
pour maintenir et renforcer la
surveillance épidémiologique des eaux
usées et pour favoriser l'installation
des purificateurs d'air dans les
établissements d'enseignement
malheureusement ils ont été déclarés
irrecevables au titre de l'article 40
enfin concernant l'école
le gouvernement a fait le choix de
laisser le virus circule et on ne
repoussant pas à rentrer mais avec le
nouveau protocole la multiplication de
tests ni les parents ni les enfants ni
les enseignants ne savent plus comment
faire nous avons le sentiment que la
stratégie de lutte contre le coc vide et
j'irai sur le court terme et que les
décisions ne prennent pas la mesure des
difficultés de mise en oeuvre quotidien
pourquoi nous proposez vous plus de
tests salivaires dans les écoles
pourquoi ne propos vous et vous pas plus
largement les ffp2 sommes-nous encore en
train de gérer des pénuries enfin plutôt
que d'invectiver les non vaccinés
quelles mesures proposées vous pour
aller vers les plus vulnérables les plus
âgées les plus isolées et les plus
précaires nous attendons beaucoup des
débats qui vont suivre pour améliorer la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
merci ma chère collègue
donner la parole maintenant notre
collègue bernard jomier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mesdames et messieurs pris dans les
rapporteurs merci chers collègues ce
texte au fond nous pose un problème de
naissance il est mal née il est mal née
et j'en veux pour preuve la façon dont
s'est déroulé le débat à l'assemblée
nationale
ce n'est pas un texte de réponse à la
vague actuelle notre rapporteur a raison
sur ce point là comme sur d'autres
d'ailleurs
et pourtant le gouvernement a tenté de
passer en force jusqu à s'offusquer que
les députés ne veuille pas délibéré à 4
heures du matin
et bien c'est compliqué politiquement
et pourtant vous savez que nous ne
sommes pas irresponsables en termes de
gestion de la crise sanitaire
d'approuver un texte qui à ce point est
une posture politique
il y avait la possibilité
monsieur le ministre de revenir devant
le parlement comme nous vous l'avions
proposé en janvier février pour faire un
point sur la situation vous ne vouliez
pas
à la fin de l'année dernière constatant
que l'épidémie devenait hors de contrôle
et que dans les écoles notamment vous
avez délibérément laissé circuler le
virus nous ne cesserons de rappeler que
le ministre de l'éducation a allégé le
protocole quand le nombre de classes
fermées augmenter et bien la situation à
échapper totalement avec le variant au
micro au certes il aurait circulé
personne aucun pays n'échappera variant
au micro main pic d'une telle intensité
nous pouvions y échapper
alors vous venez avec ce texte qui a un
autre défaut c'est que certes il faut
s'adapter mais il faut aussi que la loi
elle se projette dans la durée et
légiférer dans la durée c'est dire à nos
compatriotes que certes peut-être le
scénario optimisme seul ministre mais
qu' il faudrait mieux prévoir le
maintien d'une protection collective
élevé dans la durée pour notre
population et pour ça nous nous vous
proposons une méthode l'adoption d'un
principe sans le déguiser l'obligation
vaccinale universel parce que ça
rassemble parce que ça ne clique pas les
français entre eux parce qu'on ne dit
pas que telle profession doit les
gendarmes est à l'autre ne doit pas les
policiers parce que nous signifions
ainsi et c'est le rôle de la politique
que tous ensemble nous faisons face à
cette épidémie que nous devons tous la
protection aux soignants de notre pays à
notre système de santé et les uns aux
autres et puis après on voit les
modalités d'application et on ne posera
pas convaincre et contraindre c'est un
piège oui il ya une part de contraintes
et le pass vaccinale ou le certificat de
vaccination on l'appellera comme on veut
peut-être un des outils de contrôle nous
ne l'excluons pas nous en discuterons
les modalités mais dans un cadre bien
posé bien née et puis à le convaincre
bien sûr que personne auxquelles
personne ne veut renoncer et ceux qui
répètent que on ne mène pas assez ce
travail d'aller vers ont également
raison et bien si ce cadre était ainsi
posée nous pourrions débattre et
légiférer sereinement et non pas pour
les quinze jours à venir et encore une
fois sans efficience mais de façon
beaucoup plus durable alors voilà notre
position elle est simple elle est claire
elle a toujours été la même c'est dans
ce cadre que nous étudierons ce texte
que nous tenterons d'y apporter comme
l'a dit mon collègue jean pierre sueur
les améliorations qui sont
indispensables pour qu'on puisse le
voter etc ainsi nous respecterons les
français jouent bien
[Applaudissements]
et par les bons plans notre collègue
miriel lourde à
[Applaudissements]
ce président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il m'appartient de vous
faire valoir la position des sénateurs
du groupe l'est républicain qui malgré
les efforts pas tant de nos deux
rapporteurs ne partage pas l'opinion
majoritaire et ne voterons pas ce pass
vaccinale
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et
beaucoup de choses resteraient à dire
sur par exemple la façon dont ont été
caricaturé ceux qui étaient opposés à la
position du gouvernement parfois par des
propos qu'ils tiennent plus des pires
travers des réseaux sociaux que d'une
méthode digne de gouvernement beaucoup
de choses resteraient à dire aussi sur
la gestion parfois trop sanitaire de
cette crise qui a occulté les autres
enjeux et qui a même été jusqu'à
occulter que la santé ça ne se résume
pas à attraper ou à ne pas attraper le
virus du coc vide par l'anp ont
d'ailleurs au pédopsychiatre
beaucoup de choses aussi resterait à
dire sur les tranches philosophie de
société qui nous pousse à faire courir
tous les risques d'un vaccin somme toute
assez récent à nos enfants
plutôt que de convaincre les plus âgés
d'aller se faire vacciner
[Musique]
mais le temps est compté et je voudrais
aussi parlé de nos concitoyens qui sont
opposés à ce passe vaccinale
ceux que j'ai rencontrés ne sont pas des
irresponsables
ce ne sont pas des égoïstes ils ne sont
pas contre la science ils ne sont
parfois même pas pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux contre le gouvernement je
crois qu'il faut se rappeler que ce sont
les mêmes français qui lorsque la teinte
la plus importante aux libertés a été
portée au cours de la gestion de cette
pandémie c'est à dire le confinement se
sont pliés à cette décision ils s'y sont
pliés parce qu'ils l'ont comprise nous
ne connaissions pas ce virus nous ne
disposons pas de moyens préventifs nous
disposons pas de moyens curatifs et la
solution du confinement semblait être la
moins mauvaise des solutions
aujourd'hui s'ils sont opposés à ce
passe vaccinale c'est parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas la décision qui est
prise il ne la comprennent pas pas
seulement parce que le président de la
république indiqué nous n'arriverions
jamais à se passe vaccinale après tout
il serait malhonnête de prétendre qu'il
est simple de gérer cette pandémie et il
faut pouvoir changer d'opinion lorsque
l'effet est la réalité objective nous
amènent à changer d'opinion mais en
réalité quelle est la réalité
aujourd'hui qui nous emmènerait a changé
d'opinion chacun l'a dit ici je crois
que tout le monde en est convaincu ce
vaccin n'est que peu efficace et il ne
permet pas en tout cas d'atteindre
l'immunité collective plus nous sommes
vaccinés plus nous sommes contaminé
c'est une évidence sur laquelle personne
heureuse en revanche et ça n'est pas un
petit apport il permet de limiter les
formes graves de ce maxi de ce virus or
nous savons qui est porteur de ses
formes graves nous le savons parce que
nous avons désormais deux ans
d'ancienneté ce sont les personnes les
plus fragiles soit par leur âge soit par
leur état de santé est soit en raison
des deux et ce sont ces personnes dont
on nous dit qu'elles sont le plus
majoritairement dans les services de
soins critiques qui sont aujourd'hui en
grande difficulté
par parenthèse je dirais qu'un un
système de santé d'un pays 2 2 67
millions d'habitants qui n'arrive pas à
supporter un peu moins de 4000 personnes
en soins critiques pose la question de
savoir si ce n'est pas moi le virus que
le système de santé qui est en
difficulté et qui pose des problèmes
[Applaudissements]
ce sont ses concitoyens ceux qui sont le
plus à risque de faire des formes graves
qu'il faut aller chercher me semble-t-il
or nous sommes dans un pays où le taux
de vaccination des personnes âgées n'est
pas maximale il faut le savoir que sur
une certaine tranche d'âge et bien les
18 24 ans sont mieux vacciner que les
personnes âgées et c'est cette politique
que nous aurions voulu voir porter
pouvoir vacciner ceux qui peuvent le
mieux bénéficié des effets du vaccin et
non pas une population tout entière et à
quel prix car c'est me semble-t-il le
second écueil de ce texte qui consiste à
attaquer frontalement l'état de droit
l'état de droit c'est la fin de
l'arbitraire or aujourd'hui on vous
propose de punir des personnes parce
qu'elles ne se vaccinent pas alors même
qu'il n'ya aucune obligation vaccinale
et ça c'est tout à fait arbitraire quel
que soit ce que souhaitent nos
dirigeants quels que soient leurs envies
nous ne pouvons être soumise à ses
envies voilà pourquoi mes chers
collègues à certains d'entre nous est un
certain nombre de français sont opposés
à ce passe vaccinale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs quelques
éléments de réponse
d'abord sur la politique de test il en a
été un petit peu question pas pas
beaucoup me gauvin deux interventions
qui ont fait allusion dire que nous
répondons à toute la demande de tests
dans notre pays et d'ailleurs on peut le
reconnaître et satisfaire il ya 12
millions de français qu'on souhaitait
tester la semaine dernière ou qui ont eu
besoin d'être testé ils ont tous pu être
testés alors il ya évidemment ça crée
parfois des files d'attentes devant les
pharmacies j'en ai pleinement conscience
je remercie d'ailleurs les pharmaciens
pour leur mobilisation extraordinaire
parce qu'ils ont permis de tenir cette
montée en charge du dispositif de
dépistage mais à linverse musée
messieurs les sénateurs si j'entends ce
que c'est parce que vous avez dit mais
j'entends remonter dans l'opinion un
débat est-ce qu'on ne resterait pas trop
en france est ce qu'on ne devrait pas se
limiter à tester que certaines
catégories de population j'ai
l'impression d'un d'un retour en arrière
de ça en avant deux en arrière puisqu'il
ya deux ans justement nous disions nous
ne testons que les cas graves les cas
douteux les cas spécifiques et nous
sommes en un diagnostic
nous sommes sinon dans le système de
diagnostic clinique comme nous le
faisons habituellement avec la grippe
donc je jeu dans le débat qui commence à
monter sur fusion loutre test c'est une
demande de revenir en arrière deux en
deux ans en arrière alors même qu'on
nous demandait qu'il fallait tester tout
le monde et moi je crois que les
français quand ils ont un doute sur leur
diagnostic ils doivent pouvoir avoir une
réponse en bonne et due forme savoir
s'ils sont ou non porter du coc vide il
ne faut pas casser le thermomètre est
donc notre système tient sur la question
début du pass des enfants juste vous
redire sur les phares des enfants sur
les 12 17 ans qu'il ya eu je le dis ça
veut pas dire qu'il doit se reproduire
ici mais à l'assemblée nationale il eu
beaucoup de débats et vous en aurez ici
aussi sur la question du pass des ados
est ce qu'on doit appliquer le pass
vaccinale aux ados et la disposition qui
consiste à ne pas l'appliquer pour les
activités sportives culturelles péri et
extrascolaires a recueilli quand même je
le souligne parce que c'est la première
fois en douze textes que ça m'arrive
l'unanimité des trois cent soixante
députés présents moins de voix qu'il
avait été trouvé cet équilibre
considérant que le pass vaccinale pour
les bars et les restaurants pour les
pour les adolescents se justifier
d'autant que la plupart des adolescents
qui ne sont pas vaccinés
on pour parents des adultes qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et donc ils ne peuvent pas
de fait les emmener dans les bars et les
restaurants mais vous aurez l'occasion
d'en débattre sur le fait de crise de
fixer un seuil de péremption pour le
pass vaccinale dans la loi je chante en
parfaitement la logique est d'ailleurs
passé le rapporteur c'est c'est quelque
chose de cohérent quand on y réfléchit
de se dire en fait est ce qu'il ya un
niveau de charge sanitaire ou
épidémiques en dessous duquel on n'a
plus besoin de cet outil
le mettre dans la loi me pose des
difficultés majeures parce que nous
sommes face à des situations qui nous
montre vague après vague qu'elles sont
imprévisibles personne n'aurait pu si
nous avions dur et envisager un seuil
par exemple le nombre de contaminations
dans notre pays déclencheur des mesures
sanitaires qui aurait pu prédire qu'un
jour nous aurions 350000 contamination
24 heures donc le seuil surtout dans la
loi est rigide et nous empêchent d'agir
en revanche les dispositions actuelles
en matière d'application du bass
vaccinale renvoie à la notion d'urgence
sanitaire ne sont légitimes et que pour
des motifs sanitaires et s'il s'avérait
que la situation épidémique et sanitaire
n'était plus jugé compatible avec le
maintien du pass la justice la justice
ordonnerait à ce que ce dispositif tombe
donc il est déjà prévu par le mode parle
je parle la loi qui a été adoptée cette
espèce de garde-fous qui fait qu'à tout
moment quelqu'un peut considérer et
saisir la justice pour dire je pense que
cet outil n'est plus justifiée au regard
de la situation sanitaire est alors ne
pouvons plus utiliser
sur le
sur les dispositifs de repentir
j'entends aussi le débat et qui est tout
à fait légitime sur faut-il mettre dans
la loi faut-il passer par une une
circulaire de police une circulaire
pénale le message qu'on veut envoyer aux
français c'est le message que vous me
demander d'envoyer
modique faut convaincre les réticents
faut convaincre tous les réticents alors
oui on fait du aller vers oui les
médecins les pharmaciens et infirmiers à
domicile et s'acheva blé qui n'est les
étudiants tout le monde dans les centres
au domicile les collectivités
territoriales bien sûr je vais pas les
oublier ici au sénat les associations
sont mobilisées pour aller chercher les
personnes quittant pas vacciner mais il
ya aussi des gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés qu'il regrette et qui disposer
d'un faux passe un moment donné faux
certificats ou faux parce qu'ils se sont
dit j'aurais jamais besoin moi d'être
vaccinés ces personnes là aujourd'hui il
y en a qui se présentent en centre et
quand elles arrivent ensemble on leur
dit mais non vous avez déjà eu vent de
dos non non c'est pas vrai enfin j'ai
pas aimé dose on m'a bidouiller un truc
j'ai payé 200 balles mais en fait
maintenant je me rends compte qu'en fait
ça ça arrive et ça arrive ça arrive ce
que nous voulons c'est envoyer le
message à ces personnes que faites vous
vacciner c'est l'essentiel on efface
ardoise qui veut pas dire que si vous
contera pas quelqu'un qui à défaut passe
ou des auteurs de faux passe ils sont
exemptés de rendre des comptes devant la
justice et pour ces personnes là parce
qu'on est dans cette démarche jusqu'au
boutiste on a proposé ce dispositif
travailler avec les parlementaires à
l'assemblée nationale sur la question
des écoles je n'y reviens pas même si
j'ai eu des interventions pour redire
encore une fois le virus peut circuler
dans les écoles il peut circuler dans
tous les milieux les enfants peuvent se
contaminaient et d'ailleurs et le taux
d'incidence sur les enfants avaient été
levées il ya très peu de formes graves
chez les enfants et heureusement mais ça
peut arriver mais c'est très rare
les enfants peuvent transmettre le virus
bien malgré eux évidemment à des adultes
et dans votre entourage vous avez
sûrement des gens qui dit j'ai été
contaminé mon fils avait été contaminée
à l'école etc donc on est obligé de
continuer d'avoir suivi épidémique et a
suivi épidémiologique chez les enfants
on a un dispositif qui fonctionne hors
dispositifs de droit commun on ne lance
pas des opérations de test dans toutes
les classes dans toutes les écoles etc
faudrait des bras dans des proportions
absolument dithyrambiques or vous savez
on vaccine beaucoup et on teste beaucoup
par ailleurs et donc il a été demandé
d'avoir trois test un test initialement
antigénique ou pcr à j0 et ensuite de
tests deux auto test à la maison sachant
que l'auto tess est en train de rentrer
dans la pratique et dans la routine je
dirais d'un certain nombre de familles
françaises voyant que dans cette période
d'épidémie
galopante tout le monde était saturé les
pharmacies les laboratoires y tiennent
face à la demande de leurs 10 12
millions de tests c'est un exploit quand
on avait fait des prévisions au
ministère soit combien on arrivera à
monthey ont plafonné à 7 8 millions ils
sont en train de nous montrer qu'on
avait tort donc je remercie encore une
fois les acteurs et notamment les
pharmaciens ce que l'on donné un gros
coup de boost à semaine dernière bref il
ya des files d'attentes on n'a pas envie
que les parents attendent avec les
enfants devant les pharmacies ou dans
les laboratoires pendant deux heures et
qu'ils ne puissent pas aller travailler
qui se retrouvent pénalisés à
pragmatisme on dit maintenant on a
l'expérience de l'auto test on sait que
ça peut fonctionner on bascule en auto
test et voilà donc c'est moi je préfère
mille fois qu'on soit capable de se dire
on adapter notre dispositif pour tenir
compte de la réalité telle que vécue par
les français plutôt que de nous endetter
avec est quelque chose qui poserait plus
de difficulté et dernier point
est tout à l'heure en donnant à défi
résidera je suis toujours très attention
parce que comme les vidéos sénat parfois
font foi je je
oui monsieur hervé c'est normal c'est
justement même parfois quand on dit des
choses qui sont inexactes les gens
peuvent penser qu'elles le sont qu'elles
ne le sont pas donc je voulais vous dire
que l'adresse n'a jamais publié de
données affecte attestant qu'il y aurait
eu avec une vaccination obligatoire 45 %
de morts en moins je suis on va regarder
le doubs de réanimation - c'est pardonné
maladresse mais je sais ce qu'ils te
ment jamais prononcé sur cette question
et le logo du document que vous avez la
gentille et assez juste en remercie de
me donner n'est pas le bon ce que c'est
dresse cd r es et la cdr esf je me
demande s'il s'agit véritablement de en
tout cas ce sont pas des données qui
proviennent des ministères en aucune
façon en aucune façon merci
merci monsieur le ministre
la discussion générale est close
monsieur le président la commission des
lois
vous souhaitez exposer
combien de temps pour examiner les les
amants bouton r2 président
bien
la séance est donc suspendu
quand reprises à 17h30